every every all modern women want my  time and attention in it when I go to a  club there's 10 hot girls who think I'm  gonna get their number talk to them for  three months take them out until they  eventually decide to you know we can do  this or that or whatever and it's it's  just non-stop and they all they all  think they all think I have all the time  in the world and that they're also  special and interesting and that they  all deserve the red carpet treatment and  these women do nothing for me they do  absolutely nothing they come barely hold  a conversation they can't start a  conversation they've got no Day ideas  they don't even know how to be feminine  from they're saying that they think  wearing a tight skirt is feminine you  can stand around and guys will just  throw themselves at you which is which  is kind of like that's that's why which  is what they do and